oui il ya des lieux qui sont plus
propices à l'espionnage comme les hôtels
par exemple il ya beaucoup d' espionnage
dans les hôtels izoard ici c'est plus
l'élu technique oui oui mais on fait
dans la capitale il endort les plus
intéressantes et les organisations
internationales
l'unesco est donné ce qu alors le sait
comment à votre avis à commettre
personnes en france qui sont écoutées en
france 47 millions ou il ya peut-être un
million qui est écoutée ouais ouais
quand même
en fait vous n'imaginez pas les gens qui
sont derrière les écouteurs qui écoute
c'est les machines qui écoute en fait
tout est enregistré et après il ya les
ja il ya les algorithmes lee qui trouve
les mots clés et quand ils tombent les
mots clés là il se branche sur la
conversation et là il ya l'humain qui
arrive derrière
les américains en fait c'est quoi les
mots clés comme sont les évitant les
mots clés bombe un espion kg mais sergei
hanoune a
[Rires]
explosé juste est-ce que juste ils sont
payés par qui ces espions ça dépend ça
dépend la plupart du temps ce par les
gouvernements d'accord ouais ouais après
il ya des entreprises privées qui
peuvent se payer aussi des espions
après il ya des personnalités qui
peuvent avoir des espions ah oui la
plupart du temps c'est les gouvernements
oui j ai sergei vous expliquer par
exemple président de la république le
premier ministre et personnalité son
écoute et elles le savent elles sont pas
plus bêtes donc ça veut dire que sans
doute se sachant écouter elles vont
balancer de fausses informations mené
par le contre espionnage pour tromper
les espions et demi c'est très
intelligent mais il croit en fait que y
possèdent des téléphones qui sont
protégés qui sont cryptés et que le
service les services français leur dise
c'est impossible de les de l'est
devaient pénétrer a été les américains
l'ont fait et snowden qu'il a raconté
s'ils nous donnent qu'elle a raconté il
a demandé l'asile au pays parce qu'il a
il a révélé ça on lui a dit non millette
net il est parti chez poutine mais ce
n'était ni la sq a même raconté que
chirac était sur écoute
angela merkel
tous les dirigeants c'était sûr qu'ils
sont c'est sûr ils sont sur écoute sur
écoute par des partenaires d ali hassani
parce que ses cousines les écoutes c'est
normal les iraniens les écoutes c'est
normal le fou ce sud nord quand on les
écoute c'est normal mais sachez que vous
êtes tous sur écoute
tout le monde s'écoute parsons écoutant
fait de payer s'écoute alliés et ennemis
finalement personne n'apprend rien cc66
ici tout le monde sait qu il ya les
machines qui qui qui savent trouver
l'information ils vont après ciblé
l'information vous coûter précisément
les conversations qui les intéressent